and now let's talk about
joe biden caught on hot mike calling
peter ducey a stupid son of a [ __ ] for
asking about inflation
you know i don't know how many times i
can say the emperor has no clothes the
new york post reports
president biden called fox news white
house correspondent peter ducey a stupid
son of a [ __ ] monday after he asked
about biden he asked biden about soaring
inflation wow
do you think inflation is a political
liability ducey asked biden as the press
was ushered out of an event in the white
house east room
now i don't think but i think it's fair
to say biden didn't realize he was
actually responding i think he thought
the mic was off or whatever he says no
it's a great asset more inflation what a
stupid son of a [ __ ] but ensnared into
a hot mic the president's vulgar insult
was cut from the white house video feed
but was audible on c-span
ducey's question about inflation came
after fox news poll released sunday
found that 85 of americans are worried
about inflation which hit a forty year
high of seven percent in december
now look
joe biden this is a great question from
peter dude from peter ducey because joe
biden is presiding over massive
inflation if he was actually pressed on
this in an open setting not you know
peter did you like walking out of the
room all the reporters are yelling joe
biden would have to have to deflect or
defend rampant inflation or say yeah it
is what is what was the the phrasing is
it politically a political liability for
him to say yeah it is a political
liability but you gotta understand it's
bigger than the presidency like he could
be honest about it i suppose good luck
but he wouldn't would have been cool jen
sackey wouldn't when joe biden
questioned the legitimacy of the midterm
genseki claimed he was talking about
trump like what he what no joe biden
said that but here's why i think it's so
important because you've got this from
cnn why inflation can actually be good
for every everyday americans and bad for
rich people yo i think regular people
are good are just every day it's a
bucket of ice water thrown in their face
cause imagine you're somebody who's you
know you're probably not that smart to
be honest if you believe this stuff from
cnn and i think i'm saying that because
i'm confident nobody who watches this
show is stupid enough to believe the
lies coming out of this inflation stuff
where like inflation's actually good for
you but imagine you are somebody okay i
don't want to be too mean to these guys
let's let's imagine you know these
people are ignorant they read this story
and they're like oh i get it that makes
sense and then you hear joe biden call
someone a stupid son of a [ __ ] for
asking if it was a liability said he
said no and they're like wait a minute
but but you know cnn these media are
telling me it's not it's not bad why
would biden get so angry over this hey
maybe they're lying to you guys
yeah what do you think about that tone
man
i mean at the end of the day whether
viewers and readers are politically
astute or not
when you go to the store and a pack of
bacon that used to cost you six bucks
now costs nine bucks and price of gas is
going up if the price of eggs and milk
if you can even find them on the shelves
um i think that's where most people feel
it right they fill in their pocket books
and a lot of the political debates that
are popular in washington
again these pocketbook issues are really
i think what drive voters particularly
if if they feel like the president is
the one that's causing it right if his
policies are causing it then i
definitely think it's a political
political liability and i think that's
why he responded
so sarcastically and saying oh no it's a
great it's an asset um i think he knows
i've been feeling pretty good lately you
know watching watching joe biden gaff
and like poop his pants and kind of
stuff like that
because
you know when he says stuff like this
but regular people are experiencing the
problems it shows like it's like you
said that the debates in washington
they're so out of touch with america oh
yeah for sure like a few years ago the
way i described it was like there's this
giant maelstrom this big whirlpool that
we're all stuck in but it's shrinking
and spinning faster and faster and we're
getting ejected from it like regular
people were getting thrown from the
mainstream over having questions being
like hey i don't understand this this
particular policy while you're doing it
oh you're far right get out it's like
okay i'm out i'm gone
when now it feels like the political the
political elites and the establishment
media types are in this tiny little
section spinning in circles screaming at
the top of their lungs nobody's there
anymore nobody cares about their debates
or their arguments they know it's all
busted up so i was i was actually going
to ask you this i was going to say how
long until the war in in ukraine with
russia makes everyone forget all about
this but no that's why i said i've been
feeling good because i don't think they
will
i think i think we're at a point where
our generation
are they're not going to be sucked up
into the manipulation through war you
know what i mean i saw this video of
this girl i think it was in england
crying about the masks and what had it
done to her generation
this was devastating and this is
something every human i think should see
this at some point but i think that the
trauma that's been imposed on people
because of this covet masking mandate
stuff is no one will ever forget this
that this is now
part of the human experience to to see
this happen to a society and and god
willing that we make sure it doesn't
happen again unnecessarily i'm hoping
that that's the case yeah so i mean i
had a recent article in the blaze where
i talked about
covet 19 has unleashed a new era in sort
of american political and social life
so you know we obviously
early on in our country's history we had
a colonial period in civil war
reconstruction jim crow
i mean jim crow civil rights
i call this the era of the god king
and i think the as i call it the unholy
trinity of big government big business
big media
um have completely inverted our
political system so instead of
them seeing themselves as serving our
interests
they see us as serving their interests
and that's why they get so upset and so
vicious whenever any of us have the
audacity to to question them so it's no
longer the consent of the govern it's no
we tell you what to think don't question
us as you said if you do questions oh
you must be all right it's just like no
i just want to know why my two-year-old
has to wear a mask while you guys go out
and drink margaritas and you know go to
taibo masculist like i think those are
legitimate questions but
i mean you see this from washington
every day and the craziest part of it is
how many
liberals leftist self-proclaimed
progressives have lined up behind it
like i'm from a generation like i look
at sports
where
the the media particularly sports media
would
would reflexively take the side of
players over
over management regardless of the
dispute but now you got guys like
stephen a smith who's saying oh no kyrie
irving is a bad teammate he's terrible
you know and you have analysts on espn
who i know will never question the
narrative that's being you know pushed
down from on high and these guys are are
tools howard stern same thing oh yeah
dude i used to watch howard stern show i
mean this guy
didn't he call oprah fat recently
he did he doesn't like that it does
cross my mind but it's it's it's funny
how
you know howard stern used to be edgy
and anti-establishment yeah now he's
he's he could not if if if he licked
boot more
he'd be getting to the foot yeah he'd be
like he'd be licking this the straight
foot because he's just getting right
there
he had there was like oprah had this
party
and then it was so against the
establishment covet narrative that he
started mocking oprah and going after
over i'm like wow man like yeah yeah
that's pretty brazen to go after oprah
because she's like you know she's the
queen of culture or was for a long time
so you can see where he he's finally
found his line right it's not
you know
chucking little people through the air
it's not you know getting strippers on
tv to talk about the types of things
they do in the bedroom it's if you
disobey dr fauci's coveted you know
mandates and you're a terrible person
you're a terrible american and i hope
you die and it's like where did all of
this come from i think he's a good
example of like someone panicking um
yeah it's it's less about like i'm angry
you're not following the mandates for it
seems to be more he's about i'm afraid
of getting sick right and so he's like
in this frazzled
wild state you know of yelling at people
to do what they're told i don't know man
yeah see but but this this goes against
nature right no
pack animals never put the most neurotic
most afraid
um you know sort of animal at the front
those guys got to go to the back but
we're being led by
the anxious the fearful the neurotic
um the the docile
the gelded
and they're the ones telling everybody
else what needs to be done is this
because wealth district like because of
generational wealth
i think i think it's a cultural issue
i think that um we've been too
comfortable for too long
you know uh you you've got the concept
of the fourth th the four the fourth
turning you know stress out generational
theory you've got you know strong men
make good times all that's you know
folks aren't familiar with it strong men
make good times good times make weak men
weak men make hard times hard times make
strong men i think we're just in the
weak men phase where you've got like the
try guys on buzzy with no testosterone
and
i mean it's but i'm not saying to be
mean to him you know what i mean but
it's true right
yeah so i was thinking about this too i
did a segment on uh the low testosterone
generation because you know there's
stories going back 10 20 years about how
the the testosterone levels are rapidly
declining
some they think it might be uh the
plastics leaching in to food or
something antibiotics could be it could
be antibiotics it could be uh women's
birth control in the water supply and
then getting recycled or something like
that it could be soy consumption being
put on yeah so they spray the soy with
before they harvest it glycosates
there's a phytoestrogens in in soy
and uh there's there's there's two
arguments about this one is that
phytoestrogens being weaker than
estrogen will block your estrogen
receptors and actually
have a lower impact as opposed to your
natural estrogen because men have
estrogen in their body right but
when you're getting constantly slammed
and inundated with a weaker form of
estrogen it could have an impact so i
don't i don't exactly know the reason
but i will tell you
i think that's a contributing factor to
an overly feminized society which
results in people unwilling to take the
risks required to fix a broken system
you that that that kind of uh uh
mentality or imbalance results in
despotism it results in you know someone
like joe biden it results in these
leaders that say
you know you can't challenge them you
can't take the risk because you know
this is my personal view
based on you know research and and
things like that you know men this is a
fact men tend to take more risks right
women tend not to so if you have a
well-balanced society between men and
women you know the feminine the
masculine then then you're going to be
well off because the guy you're gonna
get some crazy guy who's like i say we
jump off the cliff and then try and i'll
try and grab on to a guy's got a
parachute and you might have a woman
who's gonna be like i think that's a
crazy risk i don't think you should do
it and then maybe talk the guys back a
little bit from going too crazy but now
we're getting just it's imbalance it's
shifting all into the femi into the into
the feminine which is it's toxic
femininity so you'll end up with people
who are unwilling to challenge system
unwilling to speak out they don't want
to go against social order it's too
risky stay the course and the storm will
all blow over you know i've got this
feeling that i really have a lot of
respect for a self-made man someone that
comes from either
medium or low means and then makes a
great empire or a career and that's
where i feel like with generational
wealth that weak young men are getting
inheriting a large amount of power
and then because they have the power
they have the tv channel and
little kids then see them and think
that's normal and they don't they're too
afraid to take any risks they don't want
to lose what they've had their whole
life whereas when you come from less
than nothing or like not much there's
nothing really to lose you just give it
your all i mean what else that's how you
got here in the first place i think
i think that makes sense yeah if you
look at this show you know i don't care
yeah well you know i mean i i definitely
think there's something to that right
the generation that
builds the wealth and hands it on to the
next generation like that next
generation sometimes they can manage and
steward but by the time you get to the
third or fourth i mean they're all about
squandering it um because they didn't
work for it so it doesn't mean as much
to them but i i remember again the very
first column i wrote for the blaze
i juxtaposed and this was sort of you
know swimming in the mainstream culture
i juxtaposed
an artist like megan the stallion right
she had a song with cardi b [ __ ] and that
was a big thing in conservative circles
and how vulgar was
and then i said
here you have megan stallion so
stallions are uncut horses wild
uncontrollable and then you have the
cultural geldings all of the men who
will be too afraid to say anything
critical about megan stallion in public
and these are guys who
again oftentimes work for corporate
media and academia if somebody like me
says look i don't want my daughter
ingesting this crap because it's garbage
and if the 90s particularly as it
relates to hip-hop was about keeping the
boys out of the gangs then the 2000s and
the 2020s are going to be keeping the
girls off of only fans and i know
exactly the type of men who would come
up and criticize me for that
right and and i think our country is
being led by those types of men white
white knights
there it is yeah white knights for sure
for sure um and i think 2022 needs to be
the year that we get rid of white
knights honestly but but it's a
combination it's um so
vox.com had an article i reference often
that like about 70 of millennial women
are democrats
so they're all voting and then you get
about uh slightly more millennial men
are republican
i think
the the the men
for the most part not completely i think
there's there's two parent trees in the
democrat voter base the ignorant default
liberal types
and the exploited exploitative i think i
think they're right and republicans have
that exploitation as well but whatever
the cultural right tends to be right now
it's an eclectic bunch of varying
political ideologies so i don't know how
you describe it but among the democrats
you've got people who are like i'm gonna
say whatever i have to this woman so
that she comes over my apartment you
know and gives me what i want
and so they're just like yeah whatever
you say oh of course right and then
you've got regular people who are just
like seems that this is what everybody
wants right so i'm going to vote for it
and then you've got people who are
willing to challenge go against the
grain risk things risk their careers and
they're going to speak up and say no
but that's why i said there's an
imbalance because the the willingness to
take risks for the betterment of society
is really low yeah it may not have
anything to do with testosterone it may
have to do with luxury
like life is just too good man i got we
got you can order pizza off the internet
you know what i mean i i think it really
has to do with too much free time we
have too much free time because we have
ex uh disposable income and when we have
free time we get into our own heads we
become uh very self-centered you become
very narcissistic and if you don't have
children and if you don't have like
fulfilling family relationships you're
gonna kind of fall apart because uh
humans demand that kind of structure
like we really don't do well without one
another it's crazy kovit has opened my
eyes man to that there are there are
followers and there are shepherds in
their sheep oh yeah there are people who
are like yo just tell me what to do and
there are people who are literally don't
you dare tell me what to do yes thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast if you want to
watch live you can check out this
channel monday through friday at 8pm
now don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you